notre objectif est de professionnaliser
la discipline en donnant un axe un peu
plus digital parce que nous voulons
aussi avoir une ouverture sur le monde
parce que le digital nous donne cette
opportunité avec une nouvelle plateforme
web qui nous donnera la possibilité de
d'avoir les classements des photos et
vidéos mais aussi nous permettre de
donner un accès aussi à la presse et
aussi aux partenaires et aussi aux
associations très important pour avoir
accès à des photos de qualité parce que
nous voulons quand même
professionnaliser la chose avec des
photos pour la meilleure gestion de
notre image poser d'une manière aussi de
rendre la discipline beaucoup plus
communicants vis-à-vis de la population
ici mais aussi ce qu'ils ont mais
l'objectif c'est ça exactement
nous voulons ouvrir cette possibilité
d'être un peu plus attractives par
l'intimé par l'apport de vidéos live
déjà principalement de photos de
meilleure qualité et aussi d'unifier
d'uniformiser notre communication aussi
avec les associations parce qu'à partir
du mois de juillet toutes les
associations disposeront de mini site
dédié
parce que nous avons constaté que
beaucoup d'entre elles n'avaient
peut-être pas les moyens de s'offrir un
site internet mais en ayant cette
opportunité elles ont déjà un pied dans
le digital
nous les accompagnons aussi dans leur
présence sur le média sociaux en les
conseillant et en les accompagnant
pour l'appellation de nos pages facebook
l'on compte instagram autres